سكس حري لا يزال يفجر مفاجاه تلو الاخرى
ويتنقل ما بين لقاءات تلفزيونيه وصحفيه
لكن المفاجاه هذه المره مختلفه وهي
احتفاظه باسرار بدل افشائها فمن بين اكثر
من 800 صفحه مليئه بالاسرار الملكيه
اختارها لي قرابه ال 400 صفحه فقط لنشرها
في كتاب سبير خوفا على مشاعر والده واخيه
نسخه كتاب سبير بصيغته النهائيه المنشوره
مؤخرا تحوي 416 صفحه مسوده الكتاب الاولى
كانت ضعفا نسخه التي صدرت وكانت تضم 8
صفحه حسب ما اكده هاري في مقابله نشرتها
صحيفته ذا تيليجراف فما الذي اخفاه او
حذفه هاري في المذكرات التي وصفها
المحللون بالمهمه الوحشيه لتدمير الاسره
الملكيه المغلفه بالعديد من التناقضات
هناك اشياء حدثت خصوصا بيني وبين اخي والى
حد ما بيني وبين والدي لا اريد ان يعرفها
العالم لانني اعتقد انهما لم يغفر لي يوما
وفي المقابله يقول هاري ايضا ان مذكراته
كان من الممكن ان تكون كتابين وكان الجزء
الصعب هو اخراج الاشياء هذه الذي وجه
سهامه باتجاه الجميع دون ان يستثنيه احدا
من العائله المالكه يصير على ان كتابه لا
يحملنا ويا سيئه تجاه عائلته ويتطلع
للمصالحه معها
الامر لا يتعلق بمحاوله اسقاط النظام
الملكي البريطاني بل بمحاوله انقاذهم من
انفسهم
الاوساط الملكيه
التزمت الصمت خلال تصريحات هذه السلبيه مع
اقتراب حفلته تتويج تشارلز الثالث مايو
المقبل لكن صحفا شعبيه عده اكدت النهاري
وميغان لم يعد موضعه ترحيب في الحدث
العالمي المرتقب